in his area
m
dave
hansen will mark
if the packers were nothing
[Applause]
and
from the fac to be alive
today
like
so that I now have
this voice
and in
washington the corpse
is not
[Applause]
and it
is Tuesday people
to know
after scaring  same people
protests already
redford
here
I think the tribe is
in favor of this saga
now
not
if that is
where they
are from speed
[Applause]
caracas
what I want
general sur
make
grass
unload
wow
s let's
see
to find out
the regression
how about
for what to absorb
[  Música]
I would like
u
really admired
this is going to download cause of getafe
that
I discard I think you [ __ ]
I see them well that they do what there is
for
[Music]
chad
ah
and
why whoever you are in the state
first mail to him his  It's missing
distributed
and
to want
after I go it's going to blow
you up I don't want to see
here
sky
ah
to my memory
s
later
is here is nobody
emarketer
yes
s [ __ ]
things
are missing 6
or
well
the video
runs
and
okay
I'll  I want
and
holder
in this for it
to remove
[Music]
if you get
[ __ ] planning pérez
this was writing bread
this anecdote
not
today
h
and
and just chat
a way
the cow
yes
sky
and
efe
for investment
to see
and
surprising x
without leaving very strong
very good that they do you that it started yesterday
in that space
pax and son has varied his sauce he
screams
and he was missing
7 h
let's see
ferrer
if there is half left over
siren
gave something of him
fire
poch
criticized
is a creation back
s manchester is from
anáhuac why
the dream
[Applause]
yes
mix logic
to clear
pass
this space
m
but most likely that now anyone
fascinated to arrive
go people
chad
the biggest smartphone
andrews
maybe
the herbs of tame
for nothing
sabat café
de la serna
wilstermann and carmen
this letter
the unit white
thus
washington
faction to daniel
in the last decade of waiting
turner
a version that stole from us h
efe
girona
de
gracia sometimes it's so easy and true
the sands
she was full
francisca ue
now
dsm iv
very well presented by
juanes damiá
jackson
if you've been around me
more
to fish
the fac
bed about it out of spite
says
and
[Applause]
hector  alterio is
going to tire